here you go baby this is Korea singing
direct to [__] Sony telling them put
another movie out well [__] you in the
ass we'll get Clooney he'll lick our nut
sack and that [__] Brad Pit
he's a [__] [__] oh
yeah we'll [__] everybody up the Koreans
are coming in they're slinging dick [__]
your
mother Koreans are rocking
[__] [__] you mother the [__]
huh you [__] with the Koreans you
[__] with the Koreans you [__] with
the
Koreans yeah what's up you bad
[__] the flying Jew and my main
man the baddest [__] Korean
[__] Kim jumjum we got my main man in
this [__] Bobby Lee direct from
The Comedy Store last night yo man
what's up baby thanks for having me on
man thank you for asking me last night I
get beg you to get on your show
embarrassing I don't want to bother
people you know me you're always such a
free spirit I couldn't even picture you
sitting here for a [__] hour I'm a
Dream Weaver dude but you're so uh
different this woman has settled you
down a little bit oh this I'm dating I
didn't want to throw you off yeah I'm
dating a jungle Asian so you know that
now is she born in the Filipino I got in
trouble once I said that once yeah you
got to be careful no I said jungle Asian
and I had then I had to apologize to
like the Vietnamese like media and stuff
but I don't even know why that's wrong
because she's a Filipino and she lives
in she from the jungle it's like saying
uh uh there's two guys blacks there's
black jungle blacks and there's jungle
City blacks jungle blacks get eaten by
tigers and City blacks get strangled by
cops or shot yeah or shot yeah or shot
don't put or choked you're right there's
different kinds there's kind different
kinds of people now was she born in the
Philippines yeah she was they're some
bad [__] I really like them I
know me too I love the Philippines the
12-year-olds have mustaches full-blown
mustaches
they're [__] tremend tremendous I
didn't even know you knew Filipino that
aming you get Nick Toro's wife is
Filipino and that's who really
introduced me to the culture then my
wife's best friend who ended up being
the baby's god parents they're Filipino
and I go over to the house all the time
I mean he did time and everything he's
in a [__] gang yeah the dude you met
that dude's a bad [__] yeah
that's a Gangland [__] he just
got out you know he's sming it out and
he got a job at one of the supermarkets
but he's still got it up and they got a
motorcycle and yeah you got to be
careful all right if you see eight
Filipinos one of them has a machete yeah
definitely you go to that parties
they're the best parties these people
that oh my God Studio 54 [__] you you go
to a Filipino party you get your dick
suck you eat a a raw bird and they take
you for $100 playing some [__]
Chinese poker that know how to [__]
play It's amazing they gamble it's
[__] tremendous and you get 19 of
them look at Pacquiao remember he had
three filled with Filipinos filled they
don't they like being together when you
go see one 19 are close by I heard like
the church he goes to in West LA is
always packed packed I went there yeah
Sacred Heart on Sunset Boulevard I go
there on Wednesdays I did this movie was
you yeah was I did this movie with the
old guy from Scarface and he was really
Catholic and one day he comes to me he's
like hey man I need to ride to church on
Wednesdays cuz I can't drive he was he
had like a those things in his eyes
where you can't see he's BL blind now
cataracts one of those so I would drive
him to church you don't do any research
you just what's that yeah [__]
research this is this is all a cuff you
know what I'm saying so and he refused
to go to the one this guy was an old guy
but he refused to go to the church in
Santa Monica because there was too many
[__] [__] over there he would tell me
so don't take me over there there's too
many [__] [__] and I go well the
other one's filled with Asians i' rather
[__] hang out with the Asians they're
good [__] people so we'd go and we'd
see all these Asians and then I always
thought they were Chinese and I kept
saying to myself why the [__] are all
these Chinese people doing in a Catholic
Church at lunchtime Bobby Lee they have
a a quick MK no priest no nothing they
just put a record player on and the
record does the whole it's tremendous
cassette player I don't know what that
be your favorite oh my God it's a half
hour they don't even give you the cookie
nothing quick they you put $5 in the
basket you're done it's the fastest mask
but it's packed with Asians on the way
out one day I saw Pacquiao and then I
put together why uh yeah you know we
never talk about Asians all time we got
an Asian on the phone on the show and
all we're Enthusiast of Bruce Lee how
are you Bobby you like Asian women love
them the vaginas are dark purple inside
yeah yeah no on the outside too yeah I
need a little lighter but he every time
we see naian girl he's like like scratch
it and smells like soy sauce or
something oh my God I love I love them
yeah smell like soy sauce they have that
kimchy little Wang it's more maybe
psychological I dat the Korean girl
eating you're eating your guy I think it
looks like tast T like soy sauce but
it's only because they're Asian really
it's in your head yeah it's saltier no
it's like me eating a girl like Mexican
girls vagina and going it's tastes like
caros but it's just probably just in my
head you know what I mean no all right
let's move on we're not doctors or
anything like that maybe you're right
maybe you're right I dat the first Asian
girl I ever dated to be honest with you
here a here A Drop in a bucket first
girl I ever dated was the first girl I
had in the first grade my little
girlfriend in the first grade her father
Drew for Charles SCH Snoopy really he's
a Chinese like J guy wouldn't even speak
English I went to the houses they gave
me candies with the paper on them they
were really Chinese people and that was
my first and then we they would order
food from around the corner I would
order food from that Chinese place was
[__] tremendous in Manhattan on 87
Street and uh Broadway and then I dated
a Korean girl in Colorado oh you did
tremendous she's great huh she's great
she was great girl tremendous she went
back to Korea to teach American to the
[__] long jeans yeah is she still
over there no no she's in my hometown
she ended up marrying a Cuban dude I'll
never date a Korean again really I dated
a Power Ranger do you know that like dat
the yellow one she's first of all you
yeah don't put the Asian one in the
yellow Power Ranger suit that's racist
cuz she's already yellow you know well
didn't they put the black dude in the
black one yeah yeah that's how they do
it but dude one night dude her name was
Patty Lee she wasn't there was two Power
Rangers the one there's one that went
into space okay she was in the space one
right and one night literally she had
long hair at 3: in the morning I was
living silver like 300 in the morning I
woke up and she was standing over me
with her hair over her face staring at
me like The Grudge like the movie The
Grudge like a Japanese ghost and I said
get the [__] out I cannot do this I I
didn't sleep for two weeks after
that do you little titties are you
Korean yeah so yeah we've talked about a
lot I'm Jewish I don't dat Jewish girls
I don't like Cub I like Cuban girls as a
friends but I don't like dating them cuz
you know yeah now you born ker Bobby Le
no man San Diego San Diego you're stand
and you have the only Brothers the one I
met yeah he's killing it right now dude
what's he doing bro I brought him on a
podcast you know who David Cho is yes
right the artist you know David right
yes so David I had my brother on the
podcast David's podcast and uh David
Fell in Love with him so he signed him
to a record deal I'm not [__] lying
bro first of all FL my brother had been
late in 10 years cuz you know you know
my brother he has a skateboard no job
right so he flew my brother to maau to
[__] 30 hookers right I got all the
photos and videos I it's show is just
crazy yeah he's crazy he's just [__]
then he flew my brother to Mexico to
[__] hookers right and then Vegas right
and then now they're in a record deal my
brother's in Hawaii right now with them
recording another album it's crazy I
didn't know your brother sang neither
did I
dude but he's doing it he I saw his show
in Downtown LA he was amazing dude he
killed it I'm like I can get maybe laid
from this you know I mean it was I was
so proud of him this is a dude dude I
had fixed his eyes he had he had bumps
on him body like warts I had to get them
removed I spent probably a million
dollars on my lifetime taking care of my
brother and now he's now on his feet
it's great how old is he
40 yeah we're old
bro I've known you for 20 years dude
serious yeah no no 97 yeah you were
doing com in '97 yes when did you start
95 wow yeah yeah yeah and you stayed in
San Diego you no no two years in so I
met you in '97 because of the fact that
when did you move to LA 97 yeah that's
when I met you met you right I Met You
in San Diego I think well then I met you
even more longer La Hoya yeah no 97 it
was 97 but I think I Met You in La Hoya
maybe maybe you were like one of the hot
shots in La yeah you came probably down
with Rogan or maybe no no I came down
there and she used to have crazy shows
then and on Wednesdays I used to always
do Latino nights oh yeah me noi Gonzalez
sure uh the thicker Mexican guy she only
had five regulars and Carlos yeah and
Freddy Freddy s so it was me Freddy
Maron so it was nine out of 10 times it
was me Maryland and Noy God it's
unbelievable and then I I met you I went
to Latino La Festival probably in San
Antonio you there but you were one of
the big shots down I the only in there
but you were one of the ones that people
talking about so I don't know if they're
saying that but M it do matter I love it
and you were tight with shamer and you
know you guys making it happened and
then we met and then you were regular at
The Comedy Store uh I got addicted to
drugs now when did you get into drugs
before when I got on Mad TV no yeah I
was sober for 12 years right then okay
we had this talk you had gone to a rehab
for Heron when you were 16 17 yeah 17
yeah and you stayed sober for a long 12
years yeah and then then I got on Mt TV
and the first day I was there they just
said one of The Producers said I'm not
going to name names because he we're
friends or whatever but he said that I
don't think that you're that funny and
that we're not going to use you a lot
you know that's what he said to me dude
first day like maybe the first week or
something and so after he said that I
was just like nah I can't I started
doing drugs again I couldn't handle it
emotionally when did you start doing
heroin well I was a 15 back then but
then I didn't relapse on heroin I took
vicadin and stuff remember I was a pill
head and I used to smuggle it I used to
smuggle it across the state and then I
used to go down to T1 CU they don't sell
vican in Mexico because I don't make it
there but I used to bring Somas and
valume and all that [__] and we used to
just [__] I used to have a pill box
and I used to come to the com store give
it away like candy remember now I
remember yeah yeah yeah I didn't know if
you were Co I was the Coke guy I know
you I never you never gave me any you
didn't like it I know you know offer you
know I like the offer if you offer then
I would be like no I don't thank you
it's
uh it's really weird that we sent across
from each other we both had the drug
problems and now our lives are in focus
and you don't do no no more coke no I
just smoke re for seven years no Coke
wow that's great no rehab No hugs no
nothing just yeah I had to do a full
turkey man I just nothing cuz if I smoke
pot then it's it's like then it it'll
Sparrow down I I think if I don't smoke
pot that eventually my temper would
flare or something and I'd be down at
the doctor's office getting
valum or something for something
eventually have to give me something to
balance me out uh it's the people that
are walking around that are crazy that
don't know they're crazy they're the
[__] up ones if you're crazy but you
keep it in cheack and you yourself know
you're crazy and you avoid the things to
make you crazy you're okay you're
halfway there you know I realized at
like 24 there
something wasn't right and then when I
went to prison and I got out would you
hit somebody over the head with a pipe
or something no I kidnapped somebody big
difference in fact he called me we've
been playing phone t uh I I uh got I I
gave him a hot UA when I was in the
halfway house and they eat they they put
you in jail for those in Boulder I had a
good attorney and he fought for me to go
to a rehab and I ended up going to an
out patient like everything was booked
up thank God cuz they were like so that
means you don't that means you live at
home in patience where you live there I
live in the halfway house so basically I
was going to my job and then going to
the uh going to the uh halfway house
from 6:00 to 9: was the out patient for
six weeks Monday through Friday 6: to 9:
they'd piss you Monday and they'd piss
you Friday or something I forget what
the [__] it was along with the piss test
I was taking out the other time and that
was the first time in my life at the age
of
27 that had ever been sat down and done
those things where you talk to people
were you in comedy then not even the
only comedy in my life was when I put a
gun on and said give me your money and
and the gun went Pam that's the only
comedy in my life in those days my
favorite kind of Comedy I was uh I was
just a kid you know 20 [__] seven bro
you know these people in America today
these people who listen to the podcast
long you turn your life around listen
after a while you got two choices either
you turn it around or you die is it that
tough to turn your life around yes and
no depending on how you look at it it
all starts with the job and going to bed
and washing your [__] and getting up in
the morning and drinking coffee and it's
a process and some people can handle it
and some people can't [__] handle it
you know I still can't [__] handle it
but I go through it every day so that's
the only reason why that's the excuse I
give myself for smoking weed you do do
what do you do it keeps me yeah do what
you do going I'm not shoplifting I'm not
hitting people in the head I'm not break
to the house I haven't robbed the
lighter they've been putting them out
for me lately they've been trying to
bait me the one on kon's been [__]
with me every time I go to that one by
The Comedy Store they've been leaving
them out that's the one I killed I broke
my home record in there like eight times
I would take people in there and show
them you took me did I take a light
front of you you took me like look I'm
going to put my hand in my pocket to
they make them think I'm grabbing money
but I'm really grabbing a lighter I'm
putting in my pocket like you had a
whole system oh my God it's crazy comedy
saved me though did it save you yes
because remember I was when I was 17 I'd
been to three rehabs right I was the
only Asian guy that got all FS like I
was just ret my parents I had Down
syndrome they really did they they took
me to like a doctor and everything they
go he doesn't have down synd him how
come he get all if he's just stupid you
know but it's like without comedy I
would be [__] I don't know what I'd
be doing I have no skill set you know so
sobriety and also comedy saved my life
if anyone out there is like thinking
about doing it just do it because it
will
literally it'll turn your life around
it'll change if you're good it'll change
everything in your life well how long
ago was Man TV cuz I remember you on TV
I know I don't have my hair but I'm only
26 so like I I remember you like Middle
School definitely High School you were
on how many years you on all I was on it
for eight years wow my God I I so I I
was around when you booked it yeah and
then you went off the deep end yeah and
they liked you so much they told you
they had an intervention they made you
go back at 8:00 at night I remember you
telling me all these stories somewhere
well I mean I Ari shaffir has a Comedy
Central you did it too with the Comedy
Central show the one that's going to be
on television right and I talked about
how they gave me an intervention and
then I was on vikin I was taking 30
vikins a day and then I I [__] my pants
and I Connie Chun sketch
live [__] came out of my stockings you
know what I mean and they said caught I
got fired and then I got sober and then
it came back on the show for six
years yeah how many VK in like when you
have an injury are you supposed to take
a day four two to four yeah four I was
taking I was in Brett Favre like yeah 30
[__] miks a day and how many did you
do that one weekend in Houston you did a
lot of something I did 30 volumes oh my
God in three days Bobby Lee yeah that'll
put down a T-Rex man that that put me
down I was talking
sideways till Friday
like I wouldn't even call the house cuz
I was calling how you doing Bobby Le
who's this it's Joey Diaz speaking to
the phone hey Joey Diaz speaking to the
phone it was [__] horrible I didn't
even go home I checked my I got out on a
Sunday I woke up in Bowmont Texas and I
made Pete the owner of the lab stop take
me to
InterContinental and I got room service
and all that Houston food and I swear to
God by Wednesday Thursday I went to my
buddy's house who was an attorney I
stayed with him and I still couldn't
talk like I didn't why' you take that
many because I had them ah you had them
do you follow me I went to I got the bow
on the Thursday and I asked cuz normal
people would might me give them all but
no you have to take it it was [__]
Bobby you've been there I know we've
been there where it's just uh I went
down there to get blow in Bowmont I was
doing the weekend bont and I went to get
powder and there was no powder but I go
what does the guy have and he goes he
got volume you know what I don't like
volume but give me 30 of them you know
cuz I knew in those days I knew a couple
Comics who liked them again you you buy
them for your comic friends you know
even if I took five I'd still give away
20 20 and I keep five at the house for
those nights when I got dead dick and I
want to get my dick or whatever you know
and I went down there and I had him I
know forget this I had him in a brown
bag like a brown Bodega bag you know
like a beer can bag and I had them in
there and I just keep going in there and
eating them and but the the the Friday
was sickening CU I had no weed so I had
no weed either so I was eating the
volumes so I started like at 7 in the
morning volumes only burn halfway the
rest go into your fat I was 400 [__]
pounds they were all over my and I kept
popping them you know you had to perform
that way I went I I got I got on the
floor the first night and did my C Mitch
Hedberg on the floor you did it lying
down yeah it's Josh Wolf it was people
know then Saturday I kept eating them
eating them and then the coke came then
I mixed it with Jager me and I just went
and then it was a little hot freak that
was at bont we started talking and she
was going to drive her boyfriend home
and come back to the hotel so we was
going back and forth then she showed up
and she put a bikini on the room and we
started eating [__] V and doing
powder then I ran out of blow at like 7
in the morning and I called my friend's
younger brother he came and got me and
took me to like the worst part of Bulma
where there's no Latinos no Mexicans no
Chinese it's just white people that hate
everybody and they took me deep into a
cabin and we bought an eight ball it was
the best blow I ever did it was mixed
with hatred you could tell it was it was
cocaine cut with hat I was [__] up
Bobby L went back she was
naked playing with a [__] when I walked
in the hotel I never seen nothing like
that wow she was just playing with a
[__] it was like on fire it was juicing
everywhere and I took my dick out and
tried to get it hard I had my it was
[__] like the I never even told the
story like it was just the creepiest
drug story like at the end this is 2005
after The Longest Yard came out I was
just going for it like I was [__]
gone I walk in the hotel room my Clos
the door and it was one of those things
that you have to walk around and there
was two beds in the room and she's balls
ass naked just [__] with five hands
in there [__] rubbing a
[__] and I go over my dick is this big
and I'm [__] trying to whack off in
her mouth and it's not getting hard and
she's sucking it and she's sucking and
she keeps going I have a boyfriend and
she'd suck it for like another two
minutes and then I love my boy this is
the [__] this is like the creepiest
morning ever and I'm hearing people at
the hotel they're in town for some
Christian thing and I'm hearing them get
ready for church and this is all going
through your head man and finally I I
ate more pills and finally I got 10 she
goes I got to go my boyfriend's picking
me up in a half hour we're going to his
parents for I like you just sucked my
dick my dead dick for three hours you're
going to sit there across from your
mother-in-law are you [__] crazy and
I remember going for the bag and they
were gone and going oh no and going
maybe she robbed me and no no no that's
what I was thinking too Che some no no
cuz she had two she wasn't even a volume
chick she was a Coke chick and I didn't
check into a rehab I just checked it for
a week and a half and I came back to LA
and kept an eye on the
monkey got to keep an eye on the monkey
when you're at that point you got to
keep an eye on the monkey cuz you might
OD you're fresh to OD you know what I'm
saying as long as you know this going in
though this is you know I was doing a
ton of coke then yeah at night only
Bobby Lee I wasn't a Coke guy in the
daytime it would destroy me you have
coffee in the morning in the morning but
here's the beauty of it you said some
words that were brilliant you said
comedy saved me
comedy definitely saved me because it
gave me a purpose yeah it gave me the uh
whenever I did anything else there was
no purpose I [__] hat it anything
else I didly whether it was uh cooking
or Mixing concrete or painting no matter
even in a warehouse when I was getting
union wages I would do the math in my
head so I'm getting 17 an hour 8 hours a
day I'm making 150 I need you know what
I'm saying like I need you just start
going you know I'm going to try to make
money and what I want to do and uh yes
it did [__] save me and it saved you
too your like I have 28 first cousins
they all went to I League schools right
so in high school I was going to Palomar
College which is a junior college like
you know Community College and like I
literally thought
oh yeah I'm going to I'm going to I'm
not I'm never never going to make any
money I couldn't get any [__] because I
look like a scallop and like I just you
know I girls didn't like me and I had no
money confidence nothing and when as
soon as I started doing standup I
started getting girls and stuff it was
crazy and then I just kept going so it
just definitely saved me I thought I was
going to die alone with no money and
poverty when you were getting on stage
all those years what were you going for
were you going for a Mad TV type show
were you going for a sick time what I
had no goal let me tell you this though
I'm telling you this right now dude I'm
[__] I people say I'm a nice guy
bobb's nice I'm not nice when it comes
to Comedy even from the [__]
beginning you [__] with my stage time
like if I hear somebody badmouth me with
a promoter or somebody that was booking
a room I would do everything I can to
[__] that person like in terms of
standup you know what I mean I have no
sympathy and I'm [__] Cutthroat dude
and I'm I'm an opportunistic person and
so that's all I I didn't have any goals
but I just knew this is something I
wanted do and if you [__] with it I
was just a [__] maniac my personal
life I'm cool I'm honest I'm you know
I'm loving I'll loan you money I
whatever you need but when it comes to
comedy dude I will [__] you first of all
this is the major leagues what do you
means if you're going to do comedy and
you start in Michigan or Boston or New
Jersey or Colorado those are the minor
leagues everything your your effort in
doing is to get here yeah or to New York
you know you're driving to go to New
York I'm getting good enough I'm getting
32 minutes you know I'm getting 38
minutes when I go to New York I get
killed you know that's what you're
putting together you're putting money
away every week in the bank you're
getting to know different people when
you get here this is the major
league and I could look at somebody now
no matter how much heat he has and I can
tell you whether he's going to make it
or not just by looking just how cuz
we've seen them come and go Legends
Montreal people we looked at and said oh
my God what dead dude there was a girl
in 99 went to Montreal I'm not going to
say her name I know her name but um she
went she had been doing comedy for 6
months she went to Montreal she got a
half a million dollar deal from Warner
Brothers right and I was a dormant at
The Comedy Store in Hollywood I was
making a dollar a day like it was
[__] sad and I used to get angry like
[__] this girl's not even that good you
know what I mean I haven't seen her
since you know because she's not a I'm a
roach you have to be a cockroach you I'm
willing to suffer and and sit in the
pain you know I'm just like you know but
you have to be strong I'm a [__] like
if you fought me dude I would I have
like brittle bones you know what I mean
I have no muscle in my body I'm just
pure fat but dude in the inside I'm a
[__] roach well you were talking
about when you came in you said it's
like hard sometimes being an actor and
waiting for a decision it must be hard
also waiting when you're first starting
out waiting for headlining gigs or or
other gigs
so it's like it's not it's not exactly a
fun that's not a fun part of their job
even when I used to work in TV every 3
months I'd be looking for a job just cuz
that's how TV is and my friends thought
I was crazy out here they're like we
have a job and I hope to work here for
20 years I'm like just not how it works
out here so it's like that that not
everyone could deal with like going to
an audition and just never hearing back
one thing that I have in common with
Bobby that why Bobby's feelings are hurt
that I didn't ask him to come on the
podcast I was kidding by the way WR
place I know but uh one of the things
that I don't I don't have much I don't
have much when it comes to Comedy but
I'm going tell you something I'm a
comedy store
comic that's big we're the
Marines we're the ones that jump off
parachutes and [__] to bring you [__]
real comedy and we're we're the last of
the mity sh products yeah we're the last
I I don't have a lot to say you don't
see me on a TV show every week you don't
see me driving a Maserati but I will
tell you what I'm one of the last
generation that she
said and I seen her throw some Savages
out of there yeah and she [__]
handpicked me from the [__] jump you
know 3 minutes to seven minutes to 10
minutes can you can you do 10 minutes
for me next week okay see and I didn't
kiss her ass I didn't sit next to her I
took that [__] ran like a
Savage we're the last of that generation
these kids are coming up not at The
Comedy Store it's The Comedy Store it's
not the MSY short generation they're
brutal The Comedy Store has changed a
lot the exterior has changed a lot the P
of it which I love I love the evolution
of something cuz we started when in the
9s right when comedy was at the lowest
point because the big television boom
happened in the late 80s and the early
'90s and in the light late 90s it was
dying it was like one of the lowest
forms of U of Show Business you know so
it's like the clubs you had way more
comics than there should have been and
little stage time which creates a really
like an aggressive and hostile
environment so it's like when you're at
The Comedy Store you have no money and
there's a thousand people signing up for
open mic and you have to be able to like
you know weave your way through that you
know and we and Joe and I were a part of
that generation of guys that like now
it's like there's internet like you can
be famous just by doing a video at in
your bed room you know but back then
that was the route sure didn't give a
[__] she would throw you to the [__]
line yeah she would and that's why I'm
lion proof what would you do like cuz it
made you laugh put you up for a year at
12:45 following
D or even something worse somebody
that's like not even good you know like
they'll put you I'm not going to name
names but like people that are were like
the worst Comics you've ever seen and
you'd have to go up after the in front
of five people at 1:30 in the morning in
front of the worst Comics you've ever
seen you did that for years did you hate
her during it cuz I like I had a bad
boss my first mov out here who I hated
during it but now I see that she helped
me but bet you didn't hate her I knew
that there's a thousand
comedians one night there was a dude
when I first got out there I was I was
out there maybe three months and it was
12:45 I was scratching for a bumper Coke
but I couldn't do it till I got off
stage age and there was a kid
complaining and somebody I think it was
Paul Mooney said you don't want your
spot put a list out there and sign up
for see how many people sign up for you
2:00 in the morning spot you should be
grateful and I sat there and said he's
right I didn't I didn't just learn
from Mitsy Shaw I learned from Paul
Mooney yeah I learned from a lot of guys
that I saw them go up there and what was
going on with their lives dice was still
coming up a lot yeah a lot well how long
did it take you Bob because I knew
that's right we were bad boys at comedy
me you and Jim Norton yeah me dies Jim
Norton we went to Vegas we went to Vegas
with Dr happy yeah that was a long time
ago that was Rivier yeah no it was yeah
no b b it was
B they had a dish of [__] Cuts in the
room yeah you and I thought it was like
we had just made it the comedy show was
so brutal that like the audiences were
two were gang members or you know like
just vampires you know what I mean and
they they weren't regular human beings
right well how many times did you go to
get ped I I got ped the first time she
saw yeah I was when I asked if you hated
her like already talked about doing it
like 20 times or something crazy like
that he must have hated her at some
point yeah but Howe Mandel showcase 48
times wow yeah so um but the thing is is
that when I did Leno for the first time
in
2000 they asked me are you scared I go
I'm not I I'm from The Comedy Store this
is this is easy easy these are regular
people I perform in front of Twilight
vampires they'll bite your dick after
the show you know she come up to you and
say [__] like you'd walk in you wouldn't
know what was really going on you'd walk
in the room on a Sunday and you walk up
the stairs to check in at the booth and
as you're making that turn that's mity
[__] Shore and she's drinking
her little drinks she ain't going
nowhere she's got a menu in her hand she
got glasses on and you're up in 15es she
also looks like a warlock yeah you from
like Lord of the Rings like she has a
cape scarves around her head you don't
know what it's like to bomb in front of
M sh oh oh oh you [__] go home do you
remember a time [__] yes I remember a
time [__] yes you also can hear her talk
so it's like when you're bombing you can
hear this light them and when they say
when she says that your heart your heart
just just disintegrates she never let me
like that she never lit me I did see her
throw out two or three comments give him
the light one night she went off Bill
Hicks my ass he's terrible give him the
[__] light give him the [__] light
she just went off she never did that to
me she always let me come off then she
go I have an idea for you I want you to
grow your beard and put a handcuff on
and tell him your Fidel's nephew I think
we'd make a riot we could sell that to
TV and you go okay you know what she did
to George Lopez right George Lopez
audition for her right and minute in she
she goes L up and George Lopez just snap
hey [__] you know what I mean I've been
on this this this you know like saying
his credits she did that to Louis CK too
one minute in this is after his HBO
specials Ling him I'm we turn to MIT and
go he's like the best comic in the
country what are you doing that's why
when she she had to she had to go
because she was losing her mind I love
her but like when you're saying light it
to L Louis K you're out a a little bit
she didn't like Jerry Seinfeld either
yeah she do like Jerry Seinfeld she do
like a lot of people man she just didn't
she doesn't like white like straight
lace white dudes you know what I mean
like regular old white dudes she you
need to have like you have to be an
albino [__] or 9 foot Samoan like she
likes like you know what I mean like a
little catch you know what I mean she
like list redheaded black eyes like if
I'm lying to you May from day one I mean
from my first nine months in comedy
people come up to me and go is MIT sh in
you yet yeah people would always ask me
is MIT sh in you yet and so I always
knew that my home was the Comm I was
just very fortunate to be get put on
there so now forget the [__]
County you go to rehab you come back on
Mad TV and you just knock it out of the
park after that what was the difference
I know man it's like what was the I
can't dude this is what happened dude
instead of letting them dictate how I
feel about myself
so it's like you know on Mondays you you
know people pitch and they write and
then Tuesdays the table read and I
wouldn't be anything so Mondays what I
would do is I would just when I got
sober I would just stay there all night
and either write or I would pitch and I
would wait I would just work really hard
and then by year three you could tell
that I was going to stay on it as long
as I wanted to which was like as soon as
that happened I was fine but like
everything in in this business you have
to go in and you have to [__] fight
it out you you know and I'm a [__] dude
and this and that you know what I mean I
am but in terms of like there are some
things that I've done that I've been
really proud of myself about and that
was one of them just be able to stick
stick it out without snapping or like
killing myself really you know but it's
like even I stayed on it for six years
and they got cancelled and now I've been
I've been on the road ever
since it's disal D two years ago bro I
was on fire dude I was on I was in the
dictator I was in h Lumar 3 and then I
got on a sitcom the NBC show animal
practice and as soon as animal practice
got cancelled 2 years nothing Animal
Practice yeah it was that and that
monkey show that was on monkey the
monkey show I was on yeah I was on a
monkey show and the monkey dude the
monkey he's about 400 Mig of THC so dude
dude you can't choose who you work with
when you show up and they go there's a
monkey on it you got you got to go you
can't go I I don't want to do it and
there was like dude there was one scene
where like like literally like it's
close up on my face in the back of the
monkey's face and I did a take that was
perfect and they go the monkey moved its
head I go [__] monkey you stupid [__]
monkey like it was they're impossible to
work with one time I turned around it
was literally going it was touching its
little vagina going did it smell I don't
know if I don't know smell not the
vagina the [__] monkey think like
when the monkey came in the room was
that smell like a came in it's also like
a hot chick right so as soon as like a
monkey walks in it's like all the
attention goes toward the monkey so
you're like [__] me I got to get off
this [__] thing this is not going to
work for
me you you did did a movie with a dog is
it harder with a dog it's [__] just
unpredictable but now these guys I do
these movies with have it to a science
because it's six movies we've done so
now they know exactly how to cut and the
first two I did with a [__] dog dog I
love the dog Lana she's great she's a
great dog she's still around Gary
Valentine has her little puppy sister
the problem is that they can't be on the
set for long hours you know you have to
pay for an animal person to come out and
no you have to take a break every 45
minutes to get oxygen and for his
eyeballs to adjust it's [__] crazy so
we had a full-blown Animal Clinic like
aside like we had to have stables and
veterinarians because Peta was going to
[__] us so they we just they they get
really there's lot of rules man when it
comes to animals you know you got to
have a body double for the
monkey you got to have like a yeah just
get no Gonzalez you know what I yeah no
you have like let's say you like a a
standing dog there's a standing dog and
then but let's say you want to hit that
dog with a car what what do you think
you do you got to get like a [__] uh
a dog to lay down they shoot it before
the car hits it and then they they pull
it back now they get the [__] dummy
dog and they put it underneath he's a
dead dog it's like a a stuffed dog okay
you mean like a stuffed D they show they
go to like the shelter and pick up like
a stray but sometimes if you watch a
movie they just use a shitty dead animal
like a a stuffed animal that a kid could
tell that's a fake yeah you know so it's
just it's tough to shoot with an animal
it's very tough to shoot with kids yeah
I heard kids are tough too cuz they got
to go to school every [__] set I've
been on that's had kids the school
teachers they're all [__]
up they're all [__] up whatever all
and they're always men and they're all
[__] up like the one guy I met has his
eyes are too spread apart he was a white
he was a white
dude you thought about that for way too
long no I swear he googly eyes he had
like [__] up eyes fish eyes I call him
fish eyes like that Mark Ellis he's got
googly eyes right but the one we saw the
one we saw last week for the dog movie
was the worst he was like an old guy
with like a hat and every time he'd sit
down like crap service people would just
get up and walk away he was that [__]
creepy so I don't know who high is he
sack te I I hate when extras talk to me
really yeah well I'll tell you why why
because it's like it's always a dude the
last thing I did right with was extras
and they were all like open micros I
started in the '90s but now they're all
professional extras
so then I'm talking you're talking to
like the producers or whatever and then
they come sit next to you like cuz we're
friends cuz we started together it's
like no man not in this environment in
this environment you're like a plant or
a lamp fixture so go do that you know
mean well I do
this no dude in a comedy club yeah fine
you're going to go up on stage and that
but dude in a thing when I'm talking to
producers they because they want to get
they want to get hired right so they
hover around you like there were friends
you know and then they you know and they
try to be funny in front of like the
director so then they get a line it's
[__] sad bro so I have to like what
you're looking at me like I'm a [__]
[__] no cuz it just happened to me
last week tell me what happened
it's because of The Comedy Store from
the beginning I always had a little
dignity if I wouldn't had The Comedy
Store from the beginning I think I would
have been one of those guys but because
I always knew that no matter what
happens on this stupid
set I always had the comy store 11:45
even if Paramount calls Mitzy and says
Joe Diaz cursed Out director mity tell
him good go [__] yourself and hang up
the phone yeah that's my boy you know
she loved all that [__] that's what she
thrived on
so when I went when I go on those sets I
always used to see Comics like the first
three or four jobs I went on I used to
see comics and how they act acted and I
go I'm not going to act like these guys
like they'd be making jokes all day and
yeah they always had a you know always
had to say something or if an extra knew
how to sing they would just sing
spontaneously oh it's it's [__] hard
it's so sad it's really sad so I I knew
how to act I always knew just to keep
your [__] mouth shut if you're doing
a scene and you already got him as to do
listen I want to try something yeah and
N Out of 10 they'll keep you [__] you
know but I never act creepy I never did
that last week I get on I my last day on
the set I pull up and we got the podcast
you know people say hello I talk to them
what do you want me to do I you know
they listen to the whatever I don't
[__] know a thousand people say
[__] hello you don't know from what
venue they could be saying hello you
know and this guy is talking to me but
he talks to me in Spanish guys I'm
[__]
deaf I'm [__] deaf it's 7 in the
morning and you want to talk to me in
[__] Spanish from a far distance like
from 10 ft away I don't know what the
[__] guy's saying I'm just smiling
you know me I just smile and shake my
head like I know what the [__] you're
talking about just to be like
polite and I kept pouring oatmeal on my
dish and I poured the [__] cancer
sugar on it and then he gets over and he
talks to me and he goes where you from I
tell him New Jersey goes no you're
Spanish yeah I'm Cuban he tells me he's
Puerto Rican okay nice to meet you you
know and I didn't know I thought he was
the [__] guy that was helping with
the food yeah right so I don't know
nothing I don't ask questions but I
don't give a [__] yeah yeah I go to my
trailer I got everything in my trailer
that trailer I worked in last week was
the size I've been in bigger jail
celles okay I've been in bigger [__]
jail celles okay not even a mirror a
couch a couch you couldn't even sit on a
chair and a thing and a little bathroom
I didn't even fit in it was like a I I
had to go to the bathroom sideways like
an airplane right this is how small it
was all right I got everything in there
I got my iPod I got a notebook a couple
pens I got my glasses I brought a Dr
jbook all right I got reefer I got
rolling papers I got a couple lighters I
got an edible I got water I got
everything in there I'll go in that
[__] trailer for 4 hours you know me
dog we don't need nothing I don't need
to talk I need to talk to nobody so I
say goodbye I don't know I thought he
[__] worked in the [__] kitchen
okay that's what I thought he was a
Spanish dude he was watching the
breakfast okay next thing you know they
call for a body double for Dean Kane and
guess who it is the cook the Puerto
Rican kid right and I'm like hey how you
doing hey yeah yeah so we do the scene
blah blah blah Dean Kan pulls over boom
boom and he comes right over me he's
like what are you doing this and like oh
I'm one of the guys I'm one of the
thieves he goes they've done like six of
them you doing all of them yeah and he
goes do have they all been big roles and
I'm like whatever you know yeah you know
who's the producer you know me I don't
know nothing yeah I don't know somewhere
in there go ask around who's the
director I don't
know you know what I mean I just show up
and tell me stand there I do what I do
you don't even know who the director is
I know who he is but he don't need to
know what's with the question it's 7:45
in morning I don't need the [__]
questions I mean it's just it's just
[__] terrible and
then I do the scene with the scene's
over we move on to the next scene now
he's out of costume
lurking with a bag and I could see that
had his head shot in there and [__]
right I'm watching all this this is what
I do I'm a professional just in case he
had a half a mill in there from the old
days I don't know I just picked up a bad
habit so now he W was sitting there in
between scenes they just
blocked and was sitting there waiting
for them to put the cameras in the
room and he walks over to the
circle to the [__] directors and the
producers before I didn't know where
they were going to sit it was a chair it
was cold out I had a hooded sweatshirt
on I sat in the last [__] chair and
put my hooded sweatshirt on then they
started sitting next to me talking about
the next scene huh so [__] Pablo here
jumps in the circle that's what oh
that's it that's what I'm saying but
here's what gets ugly
guys you ready for what he does no he
starts talking to me in
Spanish in front of five white people oh
which is just very rude yeah and he
keeps doing it and I'm like hey man yeah
I'm talking to him in English trying to
change the convers he's asking me in
Spanish who's the guy here I got to talk
to to get put on this
movie and I'm sitting at guys you have
you have no [__] you [__] up me you
[__] up me why me you shouldn't have
talked to me in the first place gu come
on you got say h hello to
everybody what you going to do he's some
little Chinese guy comes up to on a
movie set who are you he's by the
[__] food let me tell you how it goes
okay drop it hey how you doing bbby I'm
Jing Jing oh hey jing jong what do you
do a extra I walk away I couldn't hear
this [__] guy he was telling meit hey
ching ching don't talk to me ever again
you move on [__] no leave you [__] up
you got to be nice to people you got say
hello and not in that situation you [__]
no I'm on a movie set you got to be nice
to everybody how about this hi I'm ching
ching what do you do I director hi ching
ching ching Ching's the director I want
to say hello what you do [__] up I
didn't [__] up Bobby well then tell me
what happens then so now he now you're
in a situation where this guy could
[__] sabotage your [__] no you know
me better than that dog tell me what
Happ I'll throw him over the [__]
before he does something like that
so he keeps asking me and I excuse
myself and I take him over and I go
first off look at those people you see
anybody in
Spanish no why the [__] you talking
Spanish for you're saying this out loud
in front of the people no no no you know
me I'm a professional oh you do it still
I silent and I go number two yeah he
goes you know what his answer was what
when Miami Everybody Talks Spanish this
ain't [__] Miami these are white
people don't take a [__] five they're
[__] [__] you [__] no I didn't
[__] up I don't you have to listen no
you don't you don't really when I get on
a set and and there's extras there and a
couple I say hello to them because a I
was very fortunate I was maybe an extra
one time in Seattle carrying boxes in a
in a one of those what do they call
those movies when they Industrials
Industrials I was never an extra you see
how they treat those animals yeah it's
horrific but they chose to do be in that
it's not like I understand I understand
but maybe they don't know what they
getting themselves into they're not like
you and I who go with but I I got to go
you can understand both sides like you
you Bobby might you might have been nice
at one point but then something like
this happens then then now Joey I know
you're not going to but you would be it
would be okay for you to be like [__] it
I can't talk to anyone anymore because
then they I'm going to tell you a thing
okay I was on the league recently right
and my friend Dean was an extra cuz she
needs extra money right Dean and I Diana
and I are very close friends I didn't
know that she was going to be there she
saw me from she was in the stable where
all the EXC she saw me she smiled I
smiled she didn't talk to me once I'm
very good friends with her right because
she's instinctually knows right you have
to instinctually know where you're at
and if you don't I'm sorry for yelling
to you right but if you don't know then
know get to know it you have to know you
have to know you have to know went to
speak and went to just sit there and not
like a [__] moment for yeah for me
it's like when a director's talking I
don't sh shut the [__] up and listen hey
we need you to do this can I tell you
what happened once I tell I was on the
dictator the movie with Sasha my first
scene was I was so nervous I was with Ed
Norton where we coming out of a a
bathroom Larry Charles right says to me
come out the camera's going to be here
hit your mark Make sure your head is
turned to the left because then we can
the lights on your face
and then do your lines and this and that
right I go in the bathroom with Ed
Norton you know what Ed Norton says
don't do it that way I what he goes do
it this way this is better so what
you're going to do is you're going to go
out don't turn to the left go to the
right and I'm going to do this and in my
head is like what do I do do I F follow
Ed Norton or the director always the
director you know what I said to Ed
Norton I go you know what I'm going to
try it Larry's way first and then I'll
try your way second he goes okay good
idea but the thing is that you have to
know where you're at you have to know
who you're you know I'm not going to
listen to edor he's not the captain of
the ship right and these extras they
have to know where they are they're the
people that you know in the bottom where
they clean the whatever they do in the
ship you know I I I've been very lucky
I'm not a comic but I've gone I've been
in a lot of green rooms with Joey and
other
comics and Joey knows I hate it
especially when it gets me this High I
think people who are uncomfortable to be
there are uncomfortable with silence or
uncomfortable with it just being a
normal inter action where they they they
always talk too much they always try to
they have weird laughs they like they
try they they don't like it when it's
quiet like when I first met Joey I was
terrified to meet Joey cuz he was on TV
I've been very lucky that I've met a
bunch of cool people now and it's it's
not as big of a deal and I I understand
why but I think that's the biggest issue
is that they're afraid of it being quiet
no that's not what it is listen you have
gut instinct the reason why you're in
this situation with Joey right now is I
don't know you at all right but you know
how to play it all right so that's you I
have a little bit of that but no no you
listen to me you know how to play it you
know how to play it cuz you're in the
situation I was doing the Houston Improv
once and the host I don't know him they
heuse a local guy his first line to me
is this I don't know you know why I'm
hosting I'm a headliner I go you're
fired you are fired get off get out of
here I don't let people like you're be
grateful for what you have don't come up
with me Ma chees I've never heard of you
dog right so it's he doesn't know his
place you do you you don't think I know
I know listen to me right now dude if I
I'm sorry for yelling but if I was dude
if I'm in a situation right and I'm
sitting there with Barack Obama right
and Putin and I'm just sitting there I
ain't going to say
[__] right I have to know my place I'm
if they want if Putin goes give me water
I'll get get water Barack said give me a
sand I'll go get a sandwich I'll go who
taught you this it's called good
Instinct it's like it's like being just
being an knowing like in Koreans we have
this thing well respect your elders
right so it's like if my uncle says b go
give me water if I said no Uncle I'm
dead I would just hear Black I'd black
out and then I would wake up in a
hospital you don't do that right you got
to know your place dude I'm not saying
I'm the [__] but I know my place
is nothing bothers any more when people
don't know their place and at this age
now I just pray for them Bobby yeah I
don't get mad no more because it seems
like it's a different society and a lot
of people just do not know how to act
how to sit there how to approach
you how to very seldom yeah very seldom
do people especially uh I don't even
know how to describe them it's it's when
they want when they want you to do
something for them that's the weirdest
interaction I always have Lee has saw it
Lee saw it well when people want to give
me scripts and yeah it's very
uncomfortable for me I don't know what
to
say I'm very
outgoing but then again I'm very no you
have to learn Joe and you're very
outgoing but I've seen it the you to
standing by a corner by yourself yeah I
don't smoking cigarette I don't let no
no no no he's beautiful but I think
there's a difference and I just want to
make cuz we're not saying like the
people com to you at the show like the
fans of the podcast like your fans the
show the people from that I no dude I
say hi to I love my fans I'll take a
photo with anybody that wants a photo
I'll give you a hug I'll talk I don't
give a [__] that's not what I'm talking
about no I I understand but I just
didn't want people to misunderstand cuz
you're talking about in a profession
pral environment when your money depends
on this yeah exactly you know it's also
you have to know if you have the power
or not I'll give you another example I
was on heroin Kumar 3 right the [__]
medic right was one of those white dudes
that thought he could do Asian jokes so
he'd walk up to me and go he go I got
your headache medicine I go where is it
he like well you can't see because of my
eyes right and I let him do it because I
don't have the power right but one day
he comes up and he goes Ching CH he like
starts making an Asian noise John Cho
was there and JN goes if you ever do
that again you're fired to the guy the
guy got shocked and he walked away see I
don't have the power in that situation
right I'm a day player I have like five
lines but John has the power so let me
tell you something when you give me the
power I will unleash it but I know
instinctually like I don't know who this
medic is I don't want to cause any
trouble because I don't have any power
in this situation you got to know the
power I should write a book dude my mom
was very firm on that rule because I was
raised in a room with a lot of adults I
was raised in a bar so I couldn't just
run up on a conversation and go I want
that like I had to sit there and sit and
listen to that conversation and whenever
I heard I couldn't [__] really repeat
it unless my mother repeated to me later
on and if I would raise my voice for
years in Spanish it sounds a l better my
mother would look at me and go kids talk
when roosters piss roosters don't piss
something really weird with some animal
it don't piss uhhuh so she goes kids
talk and this don't piss and then you
know I was allowed to talk after the
conversation not about their
conversation I had that big time you
know you have to know
um not where you stand it's respect it's
respect and it's there's there's more to
it I forget the I'm Stone to the gills I
can tell you you're fading it's Friday
you know what I'm saying like it's it's
my clear you're clear and now you're
going to Funland I didn't even call in
for spots tonight because I know I'm
going to go with the family tonight to
some uh thing where they're singing
Christmas carols I'm going to watch
Mercy run around for 40 minutes and
drive my congratulations and drive my
[__] wife crazy and then I'm going to
take him home and uh watch uh shark tank
hopefully it's a season finale whatever
the [__] is crap I
whatever the [__] it is but no it's a
it's a very rare gift to know when to
talk and when to keep your [__] mouth
shut and I've seen it on sets with
people const and that's what turned me
off I think it was baseball where it was
very weird because it was the South Park
guys and they were banging with a
director I forget who's the big director
Zucker the Zucker Brothers directed
baseball so that was the first time
where I saw it and it was my first move
it was my first anything yeah so I
really didn't know what to expect but I
remember that's the experience I took
from that you nervous oh Jesus Christ
and I was and I was a physical I was a
psychological mess I was on blow you
know it's so intimidating when you first
do a movie like that it it's you don't
know what to you scared I remember when
I did my first movie was Harald and
Kumar the first one I wrote down every
single word from my lines a thousand
times so I wouldn't forget it and then
show up and then they had video village
where all the new line Cinema Executives
were and the director and producers and
you're like I don't even know what I'm
going to
do I'm scared was that harder or easier
with a improv or sketch you don't even
you because you they don't even you
don't let you do it you have to say the
line it wasn't that kind of movie where
they're like do whatever you want to do
oh no not Harold and Kumar with Matt TV
that was still kind of scary but movies
are scarier I think cuz with television
it's you know you can try it a bunch of
times and with movies you don't know you
know oh so you tried the sketches
multiple times yeah you'd shoot a sketch
three or four times oh okay I didn't
know that it's pretty interesting how
they shot Matt TV but before we get to
Matt TV I got to ask you something
there's couple different types of
films okay and when I got to La I did
basball basball was a mistake
audition I was a 20th Century Fox
reading for nyp D blue and I bumped into
a casting director she was walking out
the hall to see whose name was on the
list and she asked you here for an
audition
yeah read this banged it out 5500 a week
for 6 weeks oh my God one line two lines
wow I never did nothing like that I
never did nothing like that I don't know
[__] Zak brothers h yeah the South
Park guys I don't watch TV I [__]
South Park oh I know is you get there
and I see Jenny McCarthy kicking a bag
yeah one of those standing dummies she's
kicking it outside in the sun and
there's 18 people watching her and the
sweat's dripping down her back I went
and banged one out sat there and sweat
out in that hot [__] Trail until I
figured out there was air conditioning I
sat in there like a [__] victim in
one of those uh like Adam Sandler in the
Box I didn't know there was air
condition this was my first anything you
just like and the trailer was the size
of this
you just like it was the size of this
this is how big this is how much money
they spent back then this is 15 years
ago I didn't know nothing that day I'm
not going to lie to people at don't I
didn't know nothing there was no acting
class I knew The Comedy Store
11:45 if I got there before Paul Mooney
if he was running late I get 11:45
before who was the triick that moved to
New York to look like a man what do you
mean BMA bacon no no she would
hysterical you don't know nothing Le and
all of a sudden they call for you in the
trailer and they [__] you go yeah
they're ready for you you walk down and
they all right you got to stand on your
line stand on your mark what [__] what
Mark are you talking about yeah I don't
and they putting bean bags on my feet
and I'm like what the [__] this like
you're getting shot on the jib yeah what
the [__] is a j what are you talking
about okay action I said my line that
line I must have said 80 times when I
walked off that set I go I'll never work
again that was my movie career down the
two so 6 months later when I got the
call saying hey uh we're having a
Premiere if you'd like to show up and I
go what am I going to show for you
people cut me out of the scene they're
like no you're not we even put you in
the
trailer I was like come on that's how
[__] up it was then I remember doing
my first TV show for
NBC nothing Bobby I didn't know nothing
by that time I had taken a couple acting
classes and then I went and I [__]
did uh three episodes but the first day
I didn't know nothing you scared
petrified fear as you're walking like
you going to [__] your pants like like
stand the but at that time I still went
back to my roots I could do this I went
up in front of Mitsy Shore I could wipe
my ass on this I got this because of
Mitsy
Shore then she started lingering in
those days she used to linger on Mondays
too Bobby Lee and she throw a tell on it
[__] like that in Pablo Francisco and
Dane Cook and put me behind one of those
Savages or something and then I I go in
between Dane Cook and Eddie Griffin
would show up and do six hours yeah but
you know she was lingering on Monday so
that confidence and then one day I got a
call at my house hey man they're looking
for you on Matt
TV what are you talking about Matt TV
I'm not a
grounding I'm not a [__] grounding my
TV is not going to
me are you [__] crazy showing up he
did boom I went in read for the cheick
you said sit here R for some other chick
can you shoot tomorrow yeah no can you
rehearse tomorrow went in there we
didn't shoot in front of a live audience
that's what saved me pree if I would
have shot in front of a live audience
with Mad TV I would have got fired why
do you say that because I know I I would
have fell apart of the [__] SC you
would you would oh Bobby Leah you [__]
not that early Bobby not that early
that's being thrown to the Wolves that's
18 type [__] going out there and hitting
it in front of a live audience but then
you would have seen me do it and you'll
be like oh I can do that because I was a
[__]
up I wouldn't never I go line and they
go it's yes
yes I would have failed at the scene
that Matt TV would have been in front of
a live audience when they told me it was
tape like I I got I went home then and
didn't do blow like I knew there was a
guy was I in the scene what with with
you no this was four years before you
this was sketch this was 2000 Will Sasso
was in
it and the chick who I always see she's
always in Studio City there Nicole
Garcia Nicole Sullivan Nicole Garcia is
who cast me yeah Nicole's the best the
best she's the best and it was just a
Lee when I walked off the Mad TV set
that's the first time I really talk [__]
as a comedian because to me I knew I
wasn't going to be on Satur night line
but
I got mad tv okay what you get yeah yeah
yeah let me bump somebody tonight Missy
sure why you bumping cuz I did Matt TV
MSY sure let me get up there and [__]
and then you get bumped by James Stevens
III playing the [__] piano and [__]
oh my God let me give some shout outs
here real quick Charlie golla I love you
[__] crash Lance Armstrong always
on point Brandon Johnson Samson vares
you bad [__] DP Dan pazini
Huckleberry Mack Joe Aro and Stevie
mzk are you [__] kidding me or what I
didn't know Lance Armstong was a don't
what's with the question six days away
from [__] Christmas you understand me
Bobby Lee here promote something who's
there's nothing to promote yeah I'm
going to say follow me on Twitter and
Instagram Bobby Lee live you're the man
Ste no Bobby Lee live I just got to do
it every time okay Bobby Lee live Hey
listen I'm here for you okay I I love
that you came on you blew my mind you
blew my [__] mind I can't believe
this [__] this is so then now Mad TV you
get the announcement they're going to
cancel what's running through your head
it's over what's over I thought my
career was
over and then you know no yeah no I
didn't think so no dude it's like bro
when I got off of that show no one
called no they got to let you dry out
for a couple weeks it's like good week
no so it took me like 3 or 4 years I
dried out I did the road and then I came
back on fire a little bit and then I'm
now you doing random [__] you know what
I me it's just I I haven't made it yet
you made it you made it in many levels I
know but still you know I know I haven't
I didn't see you perform for six or five
years you've grown tremendously on stage
oh thanks man you've really really made
me laugh you're you're Bobby you're
Bobby Lee now no I feel good up there
man you know no you it took me a long
time and you're up there every night
somebody on Mad TV already would have
called it quits they would have said
[__] it why keep getting on stage that's
what I and you have I'll never stop you
know the uh you were talking about an
attitude when you first came on
today like I said I could tell by
people's attitude if they're going to
stay here or not because you got to be
doing a certain thing if you're not
doing that certain thing as a standup
it's not going to work out for you I
know when somebody's fa in the funk and
when somebody's working when you see
their name in three different spots
every night they're out there banging
out when you're like Jesus [__]
Christ does this guy ever take a night
off you know when I when we first got
here every [__] night we were
somewhere but it's also the only way you
can legitimately prove that you're funny
you can do a movie no matter how big the
movie is somebody will go ah he was all
right or he wasn't funny or whatever
right but you know you can't go to a
comedy club and have me Crush you know
and have somebody go even if somebody
said I didn't think it was funny yeah
but you heard the laughs you know so
it's like it's the way I tell myself
that I I should stay in it you know if I
don't know how actors do it I have some
very close friends dude that were like
on sitcoms and [__] and they had to get
waiting jobs you know I mean because
they didn't do standup right so they're
like they have to they they live by job
to job for me oh you're not going to
hire me Hollywood I'll go on the road
and I'll make I'll make just as much
money as I do on a TV show I'll go to a
holiday in in Hasbrook
Heights
I wish I mean dude you know me I made a
mistake that's my backyard I know I did
it did but you know what's [__] up
what's hasb Heights that's where it's to
Chance's draging in it's 10 minutes from
Chan's draggon in yo dude I just did a
holiday in there some of the best
Chinese food you ever have in this
country was 10 minutes from there oh
next time if I go there I'll go there
you're never going to go back there I
don't I like the couple do you really
good we'll go together to the hometown
we'll do a bar cub
a Cuban Korean bombs on your mom [__]
colums let me do some sponsor we'll get
you the [__] out of here what's up Lisa
how you doing baby boy you're not going
[__] Sushi din I have to with those
[__] Gentiles are they Mexicans or
Gentiles uh I think a mix I don't know
what our friends anybody sparked the
[__] numbers there tonight I'm going
to be the only one ston it's going to be
law school people looking at me [__]
that's why I said I'm getting you out of
this though you this is just going to
take you deeper this is Andy Dolores
she's throwing heat for the holidays
that's a new Chef speaking of which on
it okay dropping [__] knowledge
on you people what we going I'll tell
you after oh no no I'll tell you tell me
now no when you were when we were
driving home from the long from the
Laugh Factory and unbelievable was
playing and I was higher than like twice
as high as this and you were just
beeping for like the entire song the
entire song that were a
710 just all was beeps it was a line
from here to [__] Kentucky and people
trying to cut in line and I'm beeping at
them we having a great time I guess you
had to [__] beat it what you going
cut me off like what what what and then
Welcome to the Jungle came on and we
just like both stopped talking like you
turn the music down I don't know I just
remember that I was so it was crazy you
like getting high with your Uncle Joey
don't you do a 90 yeah the music isn't
that fun but it's scary sometimes what
am I going to do with you I'm have the
[__] Strang anyway on it as usual the
best I started my Alpha Brain [__]
cycle on Monday I'm back I'm back
already it's going to take a couple days
to acclimate but trust me some people
say it takes about a month I don't know
what the [__] takes but I feel good
you understand me I'm sharp we got Bobby
Lou who's sharper than [__] Death on
Two Legs Queen 76 anyway here's how
we're doing it for the holidays go on
it.com right now start right now plan it
for the new year you want to be healthy
you want to [__] shoot good loads you
we want your mind working on all [__]
levels you don't want a Bowa on got it
for you right now shroom Tech sport TCM
oil I mean they listen don't don't make
me go [__] nuts here cuz they got the
GPC Alpha Brain the t+ formula for the
testosterone high as your level the MCT
oil the coconut oil I mean it don't get
no better than this go to h.com and
press in church oh [__] and what do you
get Lisa here get 10% off of orders of
like the supplements and and all the and
all that stuff just not the uh the
kettle bells and the battle r that's
right so you got any any supplement 10%
off today and stay on it cut this [__]
go to stay on it give me your address
then mail the [__] directly to your
house on a monthly you a got to leave
the house you got to go nowhere [__] you
I'm staying in on it's coming directly
me get the H protein delicious 16 grams
of protein delicious the cocoa [__]
delicious and don't they have a lot of
sales like if you should follow them on
Twitter cuz they just had a huge sale
over Black Friday oh Black Friday follow
on it on Twitter don't [__] around go to
Twitter follow on it they rock your
world my man over Iron Dragon Dave Foley
Iron Dragon
tv.com putting it together if you're a
classic martial art head or you just
want to get into if you want to see
where this [__] started if you think the
UFC is [__] good this is way before
the ropes and people doing loop-de-loops
you'll see the evolution of classic
martial arts from the Assassins to the
thieves to 911 well 1911 911 1911 Jackie
chant effect they just got the Jackie
chant animated series I was speaking to
day Foley earlier today please do me
this favor you're going to love this
channel it's a Roku right correct you
down there check out what he's got what
do you think Lee it's amazing and and
they're going to come out with an app
for uh Android tablets so and I think
you go just go to their website and
maybe you can watch it on on your
computer start right now go to [__]
irondragon tv.com right now and press in
Joey boom and you get two free movies on
the cuff see what they got see with the
selection you smoke a number put your
feet up get some [__] haogen vanilla
forget about it better than you and the
cool and the cool thing is like I'm
canceling cable at the end of this month
that's it it's over yeah but like these
even after your two free rentals they're
only like $2 so if you like instead of
paying 150 for a bunch of stuff you
don't watch pay by pay by what you want
to watch pay for what you want to watch
no more2 $50 [__] a month you're
going working you're stabbing
[__] to pay your cable bill
forget about it start with i andragon
tv.com right now press in Joey boom
there you have it what do you think
you're dealing with some [__] and by
the way the new year starting you
haven't got your dick sucked in a year
you know why cuz you're a filthy [__]
from head to toe you got to start from
the bottom up get meundies.com I stole a
billboard today on Melrose they have a
billboard now me on these don't [__]
around they fit great that's what I used
to do Jitsu I don't wear them with jeans
I like my balls [__] be allaha fresh
what do you call it when you sit outside
of the restaurant allaha Fresco that's
how I like my nuts that's how you like
your nuts EG don't you B with that
little chin chin juice [__] dripping
in the middle of your nut sack you rub
it in you rub it on your [__]
uh anyway who gives a [__] what you R
chin to do on whatever those things the
little omelet thing that you put on and
you rub the thing inside with the Horsey
Sauce what the [__] Lee you making what
is this Chinese food night quiz here me
on these.com cut this [__] it's a good
point what my M man Bobby Lee said they
all come in different colors like the
ones I have of the of the Jungle Sabo
fan I got black one with a purple lace
[__] all that white [__] the the 80s is
done you don't want people looking
inside your underwear and [__] you got
blood in there and Lizard Juice and God
knows what else little lice eggs in
there [__] all that with black nobody
sees nothing just in case you blow a
fart and you get skid marks listen go to
me on these.com right now check out what
they got they also have a beautiful
selection for women and right now they
got free [__] shipping to the United
States and Canada [__] b b Bobby Lee
yo man where you going you got the
leather jacket you're in no hurry there
they arrest you anyway here's the
[__] deal go to meundies.com and
press in Joey boom and get free shipping
what else 20% off 20% where you going
Bobby here I got no heat they didn't
they built this like a 1929 they don't
have heat in these buildings can you
believe that [__] no no heat but a
tremendous air condition anyway go to
meundies.com right now and press in Joey
boom and what did you get 20% off yeah
20% off to start in free shipping who's
better than me unies right to your house
you see something in there you want to
buy for somebody you can fill it all out
and get the undery wear sent right to
their house plus Valentine's Day is
coming you want to get your little monky
eating what the [__] you know what I'm
saying get some new underwear get
meundies.com they're very sexy they pull
the sweat out every everything smells
delicious Bobby Lee also my main
[__] people
naturebox.com everybody's looking to get
healthy for the new year it starts right
there they're going to give you a what
free free sample box free sample box
five [__] bags how many Le four small
ones and one big one and all you got to
do is go to the box and press in Joey
boom and get it right now before the
[__] New Year see what it's all about
nutritionist approved no more eating the
[__] snacks at night you smoke a
[__] bong hit you eat some uh these
you watch your iron dragon TV who's
better than you go to naturebox.com and
get your free free I'm telling you right
now free opening up box what do they
call them sample box sample box right I
I get the I get so [__] excited I
wish I had 15 addresses send [__]
nature box to all my the office we'll
have to do that that's right we'll send
a box to the office I a card fill it out
tonight let's make this happen I love
you guys Nature Box I love you guys
meundies.com I love you hon it I love
you iron dragon TV my main man Dave fole
I love you too my main Asian you know I
love you all my heart I love you man
this means the world to me you coming on
dude I want to do anything you want man
together you're the King of Swing
I love you don't forget New Year's Eve
I'm in the a house 8:00 show listen
there's some people they just don't want
to hang out and do the countdown I'm one
of those type of people I want to be
home [__] eating something relaxing
petting my cat you understand me I'm in
Fort Lauderdale good for you for New
Year the whole weekend yeah dude go to
Fort lale the there tremendous the
casino yeah man oh [__] in fact you're
going to send Lisi at an edible
overnight and that's you going to send
him for Christmas a limo drive up to
Fort L to meet Bobby Lee's father for
one
night I got Sons anak out here waiting
for you [__] and that's it where that
you're and where are you next week I'm
here man okay so you're here till New
Year years that's why I love you like I
said I'm at the ice house I'd like to
thank all our sponsors again on it
meundies.com naturebox.com and
irondragon tv.com all right uh we'll be
back Monday we don't know what [__]
time but we'll be back Monday all right
and we'll be back Wednesday for a
special late night Christmas Eve Edition
when you're bored and lonely don't come
crying you don't got to call a hooker
we'll be there for you all right stay
black now that the show's
over don't forget to go to naturebox.com
and sign up to get your free sample box
of great tasting healthy snacks forget
the vending machine and start snacking
Smarter with delicious treats like
barbecue Kettle kernels go to
naturebox.com Joey that's naturebox.com
jooy bye Bobby
[Music]
um go to meet undies.com Joey and look
at the men's and women's under where
they have and when you go to
meundies.com jooy you're going to get
20% off of your first order and right
now you get free shipping in the US and
Canada go to on it.com and use cboard
Church to get 10% off of all the great
supplements Alpha brand new T Tech T
techport and it's code word church to
get 10% off and go to irondragon tv.com
use code word Joey to get two free
rentals to new Roku Channel with all of
your favorite martial arts
films happy Christmas Happy Christmas J
So This Is
Christmas and what have you done